[Music]
it can be tempting to think of the brain
as a computer
digital computers process information by
harnessing a network of billions of on
and off switches called transistors
and for decades neuroscientists believed
the brain functioned
in much the same way with neurons
playing the part of these simple
switches
in this understanding of the human brain
neurons themselves weren't intelligent
it was the entire network of 100 billion
neurons that made the human brain the
most advanced
information processing machine in the
known universe or so we thought
in the 1980s a more complex picture
began to emerge
we learn that neurons aren't all the
same when stimulated
individual dendrites can express
different voltages
this was the first clue that dendrites
could be processing information
independently
and that our biological computing system
might be more powerful than we
thought this is yota poirasi
a paper she co-published this year
reveals just how much we underestimated
neurons and dendrites
so when matthew larkum in his lab
discovered the presence
of some peculiar types of the druidic
spikes
he came to me and we discussed what
could be the functional
role of these spikes so the main
difference of this type of spikes
compared to the ones we know already is
the stronger the stimulus
the smaller the amplitude of the
detritic spike that they discovered
this is something that had not been seen
before in other types of animals
and we didn't know what could be their
functionality
poirazzi built a computational model of
neurons as a two-layer network
where dendrites functioned like
processors within processors
we designed the model so that it would
reproduce this decreasing amplitude
behavior what does this mean
it means that as you give the model a
stronger excitatory stimulus the output
of the model should get
smaller and we wonder what could be the
computation that would benefit from such
a feature and we thought of exclusive or
the exclusive or function known as xor
is a complex logic gate commonly seen in
neural networks
it yields a binary output of one if one
but
only one of the inputs is one in other
words
a signal is only passed on when it is
graded with the right combination of
inputs
mathematical theorists thought an entire
network of neurons would be required to
compute the xor function
and the main novelty of our work is this
is no longer true
if you have a neuron that implements
this type of a specific
transfer function that is produced by
these detritic spikes
then you can solve the exclusive oral
problem without requiring a large
network
so while it may be tempting to think
about the human brain as a computer
it's maybe more accurate to think about
it as a hundred billion tiny
supercomputers
our individual neurons are much more
powerful than the other types of neurons
we've seen before in other types of
animals
and this could in turn contribute to our
increased cognitive abilities as humans
where does one individual end and
another begin
on the surface this seems like a simple
enough question but for biologists it's
not so straightforward
viruses need host cells to replicate
slime mold amoebas spend part of their
lives as a single cell
and other parts as a massive colony that
moves like a single organism
why is the natural world clustered into
little
ordered patches that we call organisms
why is that
that's david krakauer he and his
colleagues at the santa fe institute
completely reimagined individuality
their new theory called the information
theory of individuality
argues that individuals are best thought
of not in spatial terms but in temporal
terms
we would argue that it's more general
that it's actually more profitable to
focus on
how information flows forward in time
than
the particular matter that the
information is carried by
individuals are not a static thing
they're actually
processes right so an individual is a
process
and that's a very different way of
thinking about
fundamental units in evolutionary
biology than
than we've seen in the past
the theory operates according to three
principles
[Music]
individuals can exist at any level of
biological organization
from the subcellular to the social group
individuality can be nested
with one individual living inside
another and
it exists on a continuum which means
that entities can have different degrees
of individuality
this is a kind of more fluid and
continuous notion of individuality that
encompasses potentially a broad range of
phenomena
from physical systems through the
biological
there are three kinds of individuals the
first is shaped by environmental factors
but contains most of its information
internally this is what humans and
mammals are
the second is the colonial form which
involves a more complicated relationship
between
internal and external factors the third
type is driven almost entirely by the
environment
stanislav wrote a beautiful short novel
called solaris that was made into a
wonderful
film by tcharkovsky and in that an
entire planet is an individual the
entire
ocean is sentient and that's so
counterintuitive to us we couldn't
imagine something that vast
and that fluid having this property but
why not and i think these kinds of
formalisms might allow us to detect
individuals that
are very distributed and don't conform
to our expectations based on biology
[Music]
it may seem like a truism that sleep
loss is bad for your health but we know
surprisingly little about why
scientists still don't know for example
why animals who are completely deprived
of sleep
die even more quickly than when they're
starved
jurgana regula's lab at harvard
university studies the effects of sleep
deprivation
we thought that if we deprive animals of
sleep and if we see that there's an
effect of survival and then we dig
around
the entire body in an unbiased manner
there's a chance that we may uncover
some kind of
cellular dysfunction or damage
that could explain why sleep is required
for
survival these are scans from the small
intestines of flies that were kept awake
for 10 days in regula's lab
that neon buildup is a material called
reactive oxygen species
or ros so you could see that
there is really extensive damage
extensive
oxidation of gut molecules
that follows accumulation of reactive
oxygen species so you can see damage to
dna for example and you can see cells
dying
this thing that was happening in the gut
immediately preceded the time
when animals started dying so that was a
pretty
um strong indication to us that
this might not be just the correlation
but might be
might be causative for the demise of
animals that happens
during sleep deprivation regula and her
lab were able to replicate their
findings in mice
this suggests that a fundamental job of
sleep is to regulate the ancient
biochemical process of oxidation
oxidative stress is a consequence of
sleep deprivation
and the gut is specifically
impacted by sleep loss and then that
makes you think in general about the god
kind of it's very
special role that it that it um probably
plays in in our lives right now
and also that it has played in shaping
um animals throughout evolution
you